the Battle of Wakanda in Avengers
infinity war was an event that will
reverberate throughout the MCU for years
and in one of its climactic moments two
of the Avengers biggest guns failed to
come through fans have wondered ever
since
how did fan oohs defeat vision and
Scarlet Witch so easily I thought you
were from little blue machine but you'll
die like any man the question was
answered by Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game directors Joe and
Anthony Russo during a Twitter Q&A they
conducted four Wired's tech support
series essentially they along with
screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely knew that the pair would
have to be hobbled if Thanos were to
achieve his victory visions injury early
on in the film was the circumstance
which allowed the mad Titan to narrowly
avoid a whipping at the hands of the two
heroes Joe Russo explained vision gets
skewered at the very beginning of that
fight so he's really not functioning at
full power he went on to say that vision
even becomes quote a liability in the
fight putting Scarlet Witch at a
disadvantage since she has to protect
him Anthony Russo chimed in to add this
comment about Corvus glaive sword and
his vision mentions that weapon sort of
has an effect on him that he didn't
expect Joe added that with Wanda and
vision cornered it takes the combined
might of Captain America Falcon and
Black Widow to get them out of the jam
apparently that early battle weakened
vision enough that Wanda was forced to
destroy the mine stone mounted in vision
or head to stop Thanos of course that
only stopped Thanos for a moment since
the mad Titan used the time stone to
undo her action and ripped the mind
stone from visions head himself killing
him yet again with the final piece of
the Infinity Gauntlet in place Thanos
unleashed the snap heard round the
universe producing Wanda and a slew of
other heroes to dust the Russo brothers
previously clarified shortly after
Infinity Ward's released that since they
knew that the mind stone powered vision
would be a primary target of panels in
his Black Order it was necessary to
render him vulnerable it just so
happened that glaives attack on vision
might have been the deciding factor in
the Mad Titans ultimate victory
fortunately as we all know fan OSes
victory was eventually reversed during
the events of
gained by a start gauntlet wielding
Bruce Banner after the Avengers
successful mission through time Scarlet
Witch along with all of the other dusted
heroes was revived but vision was not
since he didn't die from the first snap
this raises the question of how the
character will return for the upcoming
Disney Plus limited series Wan division
and while we don't know for sure we can
hazard a pretty good guess it's been
speculated that Wanda will use her
growing reality-warping powers to create
a nice little alternate universe one in
which vision is still alive and that
this action might lead to some serious
trouble we learned from the events of
Avengers endgame that alternate
timelines and realities are not things
which one should tamper with lightly if
Wanda's abilities evolved to be
consistent with her powers in the comics
her meddling might end up causing
serious problems those problems might
require a doctor's of assistance it's
already been announced that the events
of Wanda vision will tie directly into
Doctor Strange sequel Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness all things
considered we appear to be looking at
one heck of a double-edged sword on the
one hand
everyone loves vision and he's coming
back on the other his return will almost
certainly lead to a massive threat to
all of existence we suppose you've got
to take the bad with the good
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]